pressé par ses partenaires et surtout
par Kiev l'Allemagne a donc donné tout à
l'heure officiellement son feu vert à la
livraison de Charles léopard 2 à
l'Ukraine elle accepte aussi qu'il soit
réexporté à Kiev par des pays
partenaires le chancelier Olaf Scholtz
va s'expliquer tout à l'heure devant le
Bundes stag on rejoint tout de suite à
Berlin notre correspondant à Mayet
bonjour Anne est-ce que vous avez
davantage de détails sur ce qui va être
livré précisément
bien après des mois de débat le
gouvernement allemand confirme par le
biais d'un communiqué que l'Allemagne va
livrer des chair de combat à l'Ukraine
l'objectif étant de fournir de bataillon
de léopard 2 au pays un premier
bataillon constitué de 14 chars de
combat sera envoyé dans un rapide délai
selon le communiqué ces Charentes
proviendront des stocks de la Bundes
verts et puis Berlin confirme vous
l'avez dit également que le gouvernement
donne son feu vert aux autres Européens
volontaires qui souhaitent eux aussi
fournir des chars de combat de type
léopard à l'Ukraine cette décision fait
suite à d'intenses négociations avec les
partenaires européens et internationaux
de l'Allemagne précisent le communiqué
enfin on apprend également que la
formation des soldats Ukrainiens au
maniement de ses chars de combat sera
réalisé en Allemagne et ce dont les plus
brefs délais merci beaucoup Anne pour
ses premières précisions depuis Berlin
et puis on en reparle avec Karim yayaoui
ici en plateau bonjour Karim la pression
était considérable il faut le dire sur
Olaf chaude une pression considérable
venant d'abord des politiques allemands
de cette coalition on a entendu
notamment du côté des Verts des appels
répétés à ce que les choses s'accélèrent
que c'est Charles léopard de soi à
livrer on a entendu aussi le ministre
socialiste de la défense souligné que
c'était nécessaire de former des
Ukrainiens à l'usage de ces de ces temps
que léopard 2 ça a pris du temps aussi
parce que on s'est réfugiés en quelque
sorte devant les textes juridiques
puisque cette réexportation et bien
c'est quelque chose de relativement
complexe puisque ces pays qui ont acquis
des chars allemands doivent obtenir le
feu vert de l'Allemagne et en quelque
sorte il doit y avoir un certain nombre
d'éléments qui doivent être étudiés
avant que cette réexportation soit
possible notamment le maintien de la
paix de sécurité le respect des droits
de l'homme et surtout que cette que ces
engins qui sont exportés ne menacent pas
de conduire à l'aggravation des crises
et peut-être que du côté de la fiole si
on avait le sentiment que ça pouvait
être le cas en tout cas la pression
était énorme aussi de la part d'un
certain nombre de partenaires les
Polonais qui avaient laissé entendre
qu'ils étaient prêts finalement à
envoyer ces charlés par deux en se
passant du feu vert allemand on a
entendu le ministre des Affaires
étrangères lituanien aussi avoir des
mots assez fermes quant à la nécessité
d'envoyer ces chars et puis finalement
Olaf Scholtz c'est piégé lui-même en
quelque sorte en expliquant qu'il le
ferait qu'il enverrai des chars léopard
2 et qui laisseraient les pays qui en
ont en envoyant en Ukraine si les
Américains ouvraient la porte à l'envoi
de char Abraham c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'a fait Joe Biden tout récemment et la
livraison de ces chars léopard II Karim
pourrait-elle effectivement faire la
différence sur le terrain U alors pour
les Ukrainiens il n'y a aucun doute
parce que ils sont à leurs yeux
sous-équipés et équipés de chars
soviétiques notamment de modèles
dépassés des T72 qui datent du début des
années 70 ils en ont perdu plusieurs
centaines sur le champ de bataille
depuis le début de la guerre c'est vrai
qu'un certain nombre de pays notamment
la Pologne il y avait envoyé des t72s
des versions un petit peu modernisées de
ce char russe mais en tout cas côté
ukrainien on considère que c'est
largement insuffisant pour faire face à
la force de frappe de frappe russe c'est
un moment clé que ces chars doivent
arriver puisque un certain nombre de
conscrits à l'automne côté russe vont se
retrouver sur le champ de bataille
théoriquement au printemps prochain que
les Russes sont en train de fortifier
certaines zones le long du nièpre
notamment du côté sur le du front sud du
côté de Kerson et donc on imagine qu'il
va y avoir une offensive peut-être
importante côté russe en tout cas du
côté de l'OTAN et de il n'y a pas de
doute là-dessus et finalement se trouve
à un moment charnière c'est pour ça que
les Ukrainiens ont poussé si fort pour
que c'est matériel leur Soi livrés le
plus rapidement possible d'autant plus
qu'il faudra former les temps kystes
Ukrainiens qui n'ont travaillé en
quelque sorte qui n'ont utilisé que du
matériel soviétique écoute de la France
Karim et de ses Charles Leclerc alors on
a beaucoup parlé des Charles clercs les
Ukrainiens ont publié il y a quelques
jours sur le compte Twitter du ministère
de la Défense une petite vidéo
humoristique vantant les qualités du
Charles clair une façon d'appeler la
France à envoyer ce matériel hautement
performant un des meilleurs chars du
monde d'après les spécialistes le
problème c'est que la France n'en a pas
tant que ça il y a quelques 222 unités
une cinquantaine sont en cours de
modernisation un processus qui a
commencé en 2021 et qui s'achève en 2024
et finalement la France a assez peu à
offrir alors du côté Emmanuel Macron on
a expliqué que rien n'était exclu il y
aura peut-être une livraison de Charles
Clerc mais elle sera sans doute
symbolique peut-être une douzaine
d'unités et puis du côté de la France on
considère qu'on a envoyé des chars
légers les mx-10rc qui sont très
polyvalents et qui sont aussi des engins
offensifs avec avec une capacité de
projection peut-être supérieur à des
engins plus lourds et donc du côté de la
France on considère qu'on a beaucoup
avancé et qu'on a déjà beaucoup offert à
l'Ukraine mais évidemment symboliquement
l'envoi de Charles Clerc serait un
message très fort merci beaucoup Karine
pour toutes ces explications et je vous
rappelle donc cette information
l'Allemagne a donc donné officiellement
tout à l'heure son feu vert à la
livraison de Charley ou par 2 à
l'Ukraine elle accepte aussi qu'il soit
réexporté à Kiev par des pays
partenaires on y reviendra bien sûr dans
nos prochaines éditions